hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday august 31st
2020 this is it it's the last day of
summer
not really but it is i always felt that
way as a kid if it was the last day of
august
september meant only two things
you had to go back to school
[Applause]
[Music]
football came back even though there was
a little bit of exhibition football
that they would show very very little of
you know when i was a kid they didn't
show that [ __ ]
you know there wasn't a bunch of people
playing fantasy football
trying to break down who the [ __ ] top
three running backs are who you want to
add to your team
i'm actually thinking about playing it
this year
you know um i know a disturbingly few
names
in the nfl uh where i used to know them
all back in my football card
collecting days so um i don't know
it's you know i don't know if it's
because i'm old or whatever keep talking
about this on podcast the names have
just gotten so [ __ ] difficult
you know when hockey i mean he always
had the french guy names but the
pierre jacques you know claude
it wasn't too hard those russian
finished
[ __ ] name oh my god with the four
[ __ ] consonants in a row and then a
the letter y that i guess is sometimes a
vowel
i've just never been able to get caught
up with that and
um you know
and then uh i don't know
just black and white dudes they just go
they got all different names for when i
was a kid
you know white guys were mike john bill
bob
you know black dudes were old school
leon hank
you know simple mel miles
now i don't know it's like [ __ ] it's
like you take nine names you put them
all together
and then white kids are like they're all
named after like
uh either attitudes or like
uh obscure cities or states you know
uh or descriptions you know hunter
dakota
i don't know are they really named that
bill i don't [ __ ] know maybe it's
probably because i'm just old
i have no idea but you know there was
something exciting about going back to
school though when i was a kid
because you got new clothes i know
that's probably weird to all you younger
people but like when
when uh my generation your mother
shopped for clothes once
once a year all right other than you got
something on christmas than on your
birthday but usually not clothes on your
birthday
um christmas you get some [ __ ] uh you
know awful sweater or a shirt
button-down shirt from your grandmother
that had like [ __ ] flowers on it
um yeah you got once
she went out and she'd buy like [ __ ]
two
or three pairs of uh corduroys
you know and then a couple of shirts and
then you'd have a pair of sneakers and
that was your pa and then she'd buy them
a little bit bigger
and those are your sneakers for the year
and that was it
that was [ __ ] it the overhead that
was it you got some pencils and some
pens
you got some notebooks and then you took
the uh
the brown paper bags from the grocery
store and you covered your books and you
had to have a cover on it
if you didn't have a cover on it then uh
i don't know you got some sort of
demerit you got detention and i remember
there was this [ __ ] [ __ ] teacher
that if you had a little tear in your
book cover he would walk by your desk go
oh look look what's happening he'd stick
his finger in there and rip your
cover off and you had to have a new one
such a [ __ ]
such a content i remember having crushes
on some of the girls in my grade and i
remember all the like the prettiest
girls
like they had like their book covers
were like perfect
you know there was a way to fold it over
god it's all coming back to me where you
you taped
the cover to the actual bag
and uh all the guys were like animals we
just like cut
them and then you tape the the [ __ ]
brown paper bag to the book
and then when it came off you would be
tearing off the inside pages of the book
or whatever
parts of the paper the inside book oh
that was a long [ __ ] time ago
long time ago and every year i had hope
this is the year i'm gonna break out
and i'm gonna get back to getting good
grades and i would do all right and
somewhere in october i don't know
i just didn't have i couldn't stick with
it i didn't have the fight in me
um i got a lot of shitty grades that i
should not have gotten
you know [ __ ] one of the worst
[ __ ] things i ever did was [ __ ] up in
school like that because then i
i i didn't get to go to like some a
buddy of mine just dropped off his kid
um at like uh indiana university of
indiana
and i'm just thinking for four years
that kid's gonna get to go to college
basketball
in that amazing arena that i went to a
long time ago and bobby knight was still
there
and uh and he earned it you know
and i remember after my [ __ ] college
my high school career the [ __ ] that i i
had to like
apply to colleges like this like listen
can i just give you money to take two
classes
sorry get my phone on here um
can i just give you money to take two
courses to just demonstrate that i can
work at a college level
and i had to like strike a deal where
they would gradually work me in
you know like a non-italian trying to
work his way into the mob and i could
only get so far
back in the day right so um
anyway uh yeah that's what i did and i
gradually
uh worked my way
into the university of massachusetts
boston and eventually transferred to
emerson college after that
and even that one i had to kind of do
the same thing how many credits are we
going to take took me forever
you know if i just buckled down and
applied myself
i could have been out i actually to this
day still think like what if i [ __ ]
actually did well in school but then
even then i still want to rush through
college just so i can become a comedian
so i started thinking well what if i
picked up a semester over the summer
before i was supposed to go and then
i'd be dealt with my freshman year
december
of the year i graduated high school and
i just i just keep blowing through the
[ __ ]
um the summers picking up a semester
each time i'd be done in like two and a
half years or something
and then i'd finally be not only caught
up i'd be ahead
because i stayed back in first grade and
i always just felt like my whole life
i've just felt like i've been behind
um and the reality is there's nothing i
can do about it but that doesn't stop me
in my 50s of still
thinking about this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me
um so anywho hey guess what
guess what i finally i got a [ __ ] i
got some social distance
uh tour dates coming up you know
everybody else is back to work i have to
work i have a mortgage
just like you so you guys you guys are
just regular people you put your pant
legs on you know one leg at a time i'm
in show business
i jump into my slacks both legs
same time um
i'm gonna be doing uh twilight comedy on
the farm
at south farms just 15 miles outside of
bristol connecticut
uh the september 23rd shows the early
show and the late shows are sold out
uh thank god thank you guys so much so
we added two shows
uh september 24th tickets are live now
you can go to billboard.com for the
ticket links
um and then um we're gonna try to just
we're just gonna see
where this goes how many shows i can add
and then i'll be back east so
then we might if the ticket sales go
well
there then maybe i don't know maybe i do
something else maybe i don't i'd have no
idea
um all i know is um
yeah i have to get back out and i have
to go back to work because i got a wife
and two kids and a [ __ ] mortgage
and all of this [ __ ] you know we
downsized a little bit we've pulled back
we've uh
tightened the [ __ ] bootstraps that
you pull yourself up while you've
since your belt a little closer around
your waist whatever the [ __ ]
expression is
um no i have to uh yeah i got to stop
dipping into the
uh rainy day fund here and i got to go
out and go make some [ __ ] money
that's basically it okay
i can't i can't [ __ ] sit around doing
nothing all right it was a great
it really wasn't a great five months it
really wasn't because there was always
the
the frustration and the fear of the
unknown um
but you know whatever i took off some
weight i put it back on and i took it
off
took it back off again all that weight
that i gained when i was out in yellow
springs one of my new favorite parts of
the [ __ ] world
i've thought about that milkshake that i
got at the jersey dairy farm out there
i got to get the right name for that
place let me see here
is my internet working is the internet
working
jersey farm yellow springs
ohio come on
come on bessie come on buddy there we go
oh young's jersey dairy homemade ice
cream and family fun
it's just [ __ ] tremendous i'm telling
you for the rest of my standup career
if i'm ever in cincinnati if i'm ever in
dayton i'm driving over there
like a [ __ ] crack feed their ice it
was like heroin
it was that [ __ ] good tremendous old
billy sweet tooth
so i came back i was a bloated i was
filled with salt and sugar uh speaking
of back to school i was eating like i
was still in grade school and like i
said i went to the local juice place
they had a really cool t-shirt i still
got it in a medium
and i put that [ __ ] on and i was like
a [ __ ]
you know you know when you cook a hot
dog right before it splits
that's what the [ __ ] i look like in this
goddamn thing
one of those things if i reach forward
like my this separation between
my lower back where the shirt is in my
pants was like at least
almost probably a full foot um
and that's all because you know it's all
in my arms and my
[ __ ] man tits and all of that [ __ ] so
i have eaten like a
saint uh since i got back
and now uh like i said if i eat bad for
seven days i need to be
a saint for 18 days that's kind of how
it works it's almost a three to one
ratio um
good to bad bad the good however that
[ __ ] works out so
i've just been eating uh perfectly
and um you know occasionally once a week
you're supposed to have like a high
calorie day
just so your metabolism doesn't get used
to eating perfect because that's the
worst because then you're eating perfect
and you're not seeing the results
um so last night i had a little steak
dinner with corn on the cob my favorite
i only eat corn on the cob in august
that's it
uh back in the day that's when my mother
would go out and get it
my mother she was like it's fresh they
got corn in the cab
right the rest of the year was frozen
corn which absolutely sucked
and i've had an ongoing debate with my
great friend paul verzi
where uh he has two things that he says
no use for
in his diet it's corn and peas
and i just you know he's
he's sicilian and greek and i'm
basically german irish with some
scottish in me so you know there's
in my world there's nothing better than
mashed potatoes with some with some peas
even better if you put them in one of
those [ __ ] little pies there and
they're both mixed in together
i love peas and i also um
i love corn but it's got to be corn on
the cob you know
that [ __ ] frozen corn where they had
like the back in the day where they had
like the butter inside of it too
was just uh there was there's something
wrong about that like you just didn't
feel right after you uh
after you ate it but i know there's
going to be a lot of people going like
you know how you call paul is right
about corn is because you shed it out
and it still looks like corn your body
has no use to it
use for it has not used it at all um
although i saw this documentary on food
one time and it said that basically
everything
was made out of corn so i don't know
what to tell you
um oh man i went down a
[ __ ] amazing rabbit hole last night
um i just you know from watching that uh
oh it's [ __ ] hilarious whatever the
hell that guy's name was that [ __ ]
documentary i was making fun of that
music producer who's
like ron if ron burgundy was a real
person
david foster so i got it got me back
into early chicago which is something
that i always
wanted to kind of get into i just never
got around to it
um because i was too busy into my medal
man
and um
you know nia loves that it's funny nia
is into all of that
early 70s like she likes to band america
she likes chicago she's really into that
she has like these different
um eras of music that she's like totally
into
like i know she's into like uh i don't
know if it's
like r b or whatever something from the
early 90s she absolutely loves it
um so i started watching this
documentary that terry cath's daughter
made
um and i i didn't get any sleep the
night before so i can't remember the
name of it
i think it was the terry cath experience
and um
basically this [ __ ] guitarist i've
told you about him before
he was so good i didn't know this like
jimi hendrix
saw those guys and saw terry cath and
was so blown away by them that he took
them on tour
he had them open up for them and he was
telling everybody going you know terry's
a better guitarist than i am
and that is why jimi hendrix was so
great
because there's a lot of [ __ ] people
in show business that when they see a
beast coming up
they want to get away from them and have
some cupcake open for them but the true
greats
who even when they're they're considered
the greatest out there are
are not afraid to be challenged and want
to be pushed because
their passion is not that stupid list
that they're on it's about continuing to
get better at what it is that they do
so it made me love jimi hendrix even
more
and uh and terry kathy even more and uh
you got to watch it it's called uh the
terry cath
experience and um
you know they get into all of uh a lot
of stuff that i didn't know
i didn't know where the band was at and
how terry was looking to do a solo
album um at the time that he left and i
also owed david foster
a little bit of an apology because i was
saying he took the balls out of the band
but
you know while terry was still in the
band they had that number one hit
in 1976. if you leave me now
remember that song if you leave me now
you take away the biggest part of me
[Music]
that song when i was a kid even when i
was a kid
it kind of used to depress me and i'll
be honest with you a lot of chicago's
music uh there was something about i
don't know what key it's in or whatever
but it kind of uh
i don't know would bring me down a
little bit
there's certain music that i i totally
respect but if i listen to it because of
the way i'm wired and prone to
depression
like it [ __ ] drags me down john
legend
another one my wife loves john legend
when i when he [ __ ] we're just
ordinary people when i hear that
ordinary people song i
i want to go put a [ __ ] gun in my
mouth
not literally everybody relax i don't
need to [ __ ] phone a friend here
i'm just saying i just there's something
about that like
i don't know what it is about the song i
can't even name any more lyrics after
this
i like fighting my head you're not
ordinary people you're special
you just got you haven't found your
thing yet
um yeah but now
i think that i'm older more mature and
more [ __ ] chilled out and have a
better feeling about myself now i go
back and i listen to
that early chicago including that
that that song that they won their first
grammy on baby please don't go and i
absolutely
love it and um
i'm fascinated with the band especially
that drummer
danny serafin i think his name is um the
size of his bass drum
because it looks like he's only playing
like a 20-inch bass drum
and you got that hold that horn section
you got terry um
you got peter cetera you got all of
these monsters
on stage that are killing it and you
would think that he would need at least
a 22.
um i was kind of surprised but yet not
surprised because all of those guys who
were such great drummers back then they
all kind of grew up listening to jazz
because that was more like mainstream i
think
um so they all kind of had that swing
pulse in their playing and that's why i
just think the drummers back then
were um
a lot of it was a lot more interesting
as far as like the white drums i feel
because because they did listen to jazz
they had more of a swing
in what they were playing where the
white dramas that came after that kind
of started with this real heavy
sabbath zeppelin and all of that and
they kind of missed out on
the swing music and if you just sort of
started with that
i don't know i have this weird theory
about white people clapping on the
downbeat
because if you if you watch some old
jazz [ __ ] in old jazz clubs or whatever
maybe dave brubeck where it's like a
really white crowd you see them clapping
on two and four
and then somewhere when rock music got
really [ __ ] heavy
because even rock and roll still kind of
had that swing pulse to it but when you
get into the 60s
where you know zeppelin the who
black sabbath and music started getting
like really heavy
all of a sudden there was the clapping
on either one and three or on all four
beats
um because i think it was just i don't
know it was
just the the phrasing of it i think just
doesn't take much to throw us off but i
don't think we've ever recovered
speaking speaking of not recovering
let's go through the nhl playoffs my
beloved boston bruins
are down three games to one
to the tampa bay lightning
is there anything worse than losing
to to to a [ __ ] team that's named
after a goddamn weather report
you know we're just all out of animals
a lot of ferocious things to name teams
after and then you just gotta be like
the uh the hurricanes
the lightning the uh
i don't even know what what the [ __ ]
else could you be named after
what the [ __ ] do they call that a uh
what is that inversion where all of a
sudden just air comes come
crashing down like a [ __ ] skyscraper
a microburst the microbursts
you can't say that because then
everybody will talk about dick size
um yeah we are down to the tampa bay
lightning who are just playing great
and uh you know we've taken a couple of
stupid penalties
took a five minute major boarding
penalty in the last one
uh you know not arguing the call that's
exactly what it was
and then they they scored the third goal
um which just really put us in a hole
and
considering that we got halak in net
where the way he's been thrown in there
um we need to be playing with the lead
and we're not and then on top of that
we're then taking dumb penalties and
that right there's a recipe for being
done three to one now
i think my bruins have too much hot i
don't think they're going to lose today
then it becomes 3-2 then it's
interesting
then it's interesting uh your number one
seed in the east
philadelphia flyers the creamsicles
kind of saw this one coming down three
to one
to the very quiet and dangerous uh
new york islanders um
vancouver canucks down three games to
one
to the [ __ ] uh the vegas knights
were looking strong as [ __ ] and then the
colorado avalanche who lie i believe
they lost their goaltender for the
series at least for a couple of games he
split his [ __ ] taint in the first
game or his nut sack something happened
uh they're down three game also down
three games to one
to the dallas stars so
i was talking to a buddy of mine he said
uh before this round he goes it's gonna
be tampa versus vancouver
i'm sorry tampa versus uh vegas in the
finals that was his prediction
and um my prediction of course was the
bruins
first vegas and the bruins win a cup i
mean i thought that that was a lock
i'm kidding we you know we were behind
the eight pole okay goddamn goaltender
left what are we supposed to do okay
respect the fact i expect the reasons
respect the reasons why he left but that
definitely left us kind of uh
in a bit of a pickle as they say
so um i don't know just as a fan of
hockey i don't like
that everybody's down three games to one
because i want to see as much hockey as
possible
um although when this thing ends don't
they just start right back up again
in october kidding
how the [ __ ] are they gonna get
everything lined back up again
where if these playoffs are gonna go
into october i mean not at this rate if
everybody wins in like [ __ ] five
games
um my question
then is is if this if you've delayed the
start of
the do you play a shortened season
or do you i don't know
just fix it over two seasons i have no
idea the only thing i know
is that it's the nhl so god knows
they're gonna do something [ __ ] weird
that makes no sense which is why i love
and also get super frustrated
with uh with the nhl
um lewis hamilton wins again
in belgium um it's funny the f1 it's
just the same [ __ ] [ __ ] every week
but it's still exciting to watch but
it's just lewis hamilton
wins pole gets out of the first turn in
first place and the [ __ ] race is over
uh the the most excitement of this past
race was watching daniel ricardo
um he had a great race uh just a great
driver and i just wish she was on a
better team
um there's just every race though it
just seems to be
uh you know louis and then it's either
max verstappen or [ __ ] botos
and then uh maybe vettel
every race it just seems to be the same
[ __ ] thing they think they got to do
something
i don't know what they have to do you
know maybe the other teams can [ __ ]
step it up
peek into the mercedes
little pit there and see what the [ __ ]
it is they're doing try to i don't get
it step up your game
something and i also finally i'm two
races behind a moto gp i finally saw
that moto gp race where they had that
horrific
[ __ ] crash uh which i saw the replay
of the day it happened but like to watch
it sort of with the race going on
um i mean i can't believe somebody
didn't get killed if you didn't see it
basically they were coming down a
straightaway going close to 200 miles an
hour
two bikes touched and at the end of the
end of the straightaway you know you got
a break hard
and then make a right turn and these
guys
collided on the right-hand side of the
track so their bikes
got twisted up one of them like you know
continued on straight they both did the
wreckage of one the other continued on
straight and
hit one of those air walls but the other
one
which still had like the i believe the
engine in it
the wheels were gone was like going end
over end
as these guys were making a right turn
and
it was looking like it was going to just
like broadside somebody on a bike
and the bike had to be still going over
100 miles an hour just going end over
end
and it literally threaded the needle
between valentino rossi in front of his
bike and i forget who else was there
um i forget
who's zarko who's on one of the bikes i
forget if it was vinales i don't know
who the hell it was
but like literally
the shot that they have the on-board
camera
of uh valentino rossi you know he's
looking his way through the turn and
then just all of a sudden like right in
front of him
this [ __ ] motorcycle cartwheels
nobody on it parts just hanging off of
it you see him like whoa what the [ __ ]
and then he just rolls back on the
throttle like a [ __ ] lunatic because
i would i would just pull over i don't
want to do this anymore
and uh they actually had to stop the
race
and these guys went into the pits which
was probably worse because then they had
to really sit there and think about it
i would just go into the mindset of like
all right well what's the odds of that
happening again in this race
that's the only place you could go and
there was one of the one of the guys on
the ktm bikes i figured
i forget the name of the guy he was all
[ __ ] pissed because he was leading
the race and was looking like he was
going to win it
and then he went out there and i thought
he went into a real
bill burr mindset where he was [ __ ]
pissed and uh
he let his emotions get the best of them
and he ended up crashing because he was
so trying to get back you know he seemed
like a hot head i really like related to
the guy
and i felt bad when he crashed out of
the race so i would be watching the next
race wherever the [ __ ] that one is to
get caught up so this weekend
if they have another one this weekend i
will be all caught up
um all right so that is it let's do a
little bit of um
let's let's do a little bit of
advertising here
uh oh look who it is everybody it's all
zip
talk about how challenging hiring can be
for business owners
uh yeah it could be it's always always
was difficult but now somebody could
have the uh the covet or some [ __ ]
um you know how the hell do you even
meet people nowadays
you know they got to be six feet away
you know your desk is only three feet
long wide or some [ __ ] right
sitting there shouting questions at them
i don't know wouldn't it be easier if
you just [ __ ] go online and have uh
some why are you making me do all of
this i don't know what to do here
monica starks could relate okay anyways
especially
uh with everything else they have to
think about these days enforcing social
distancing supplying mass for their
employees etc
that's what i was trying to get to
monica starks everybody could relate
uh she needs to hire i always like that
name monica she needs to hire for a
pivotal role
she needed sorry to hire for a pivotal
role at her construction company gs
group
but was having a tough time finding the
right person especially with so many
candidates out there so she switched to
zip
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you
it goes on the offensive uh it's not
acting like the hot chick at the bar
waiting for somebody to buy a drink
right
it's out there on the dance floor
shaking its ass throwing out that
personality
like a strong six does at the club it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience for your job and
actively
invites them to apply which is why you
should try zip
well for free at ziprecruiter.com
that's how monica found lamont jenkins
lamont wow i didn't know somebody named
somebody
lamont you big dummy you been hired uh
she said that zip recruiters sent
lamont's profile
to her around five minutes after she
posted a job because he was a great
match for the role well yeah he had all
that
experience working for his dad in the
junkyard he'd be great at the
construction company imagine actually
having new
parts that fit um
through zip uh monica
company has hired everyone from
accountants to project managers
to field scientists monica's not
the only employer who loves zip
recruiter four out of five
employees who post on
[Music]
uh zip a quality candidate within the
first day see yourself
see for yourself how ziprecruiter makes
hiring faster and easier try it now for
free
that's right free at ziprecruiter.com
that's ziprecruiter.com
spell it out cip
ah e c r u i t e r dot com slash bur
all right oh look who's here everybody
uh butcher box oh i love these people i
love these what
what i mean what a perfect company a
perfect way
to bring quality meats to people during
a pandemic
okay if you don't want to go down the
the goddamn grocery store and deal with
all
that [ __ ] with the mass you can just
stay at home you know when it comes to
when it comes to meat quality matters
but there's more to it
than texture and taste lux luckily
there's butcher box butcher box believes
everyone deserves high quality
humanely sourced meat never be without
something to cook for dinner because
there's always meat in the
freezer
one less trip to the grocery store and a
better more affordable selection
two yeah plus if you just order from
butcher bucks when you do go to the
grocery store
all you got to do is go into the fruits
and veggies section big bang boom you
got all your sides you're ready to go a
little bit of [ __ ]
eggs butter and milk you're out the door
um talk about your experience with
butcher box well i just
they just bring it right to me and i
cook it up and they're pork chop
the heritage breed pork is my favorite
pork chop i've ever made at home
it's absolutely delicious each box has 9
to 11 pounds of meat
uh enough for 24 individual meals
or seven if you ate the way i did in uh
yellow springs
uh packed fresh and shipped frozen and
vacuum sealed so it stays that way i can
customize my box
or go with one of theirs either way i
get exactly what i want
options like a hundred percent grass-fed
and fresh and finished beef
free-range organic chicken heritage pork
my favorite
wild caught alaska and you don't know
what they're gonna do
that crazy salmon lifting their scales
up showing their titties
uh and sugar nitrate free bacon butcher
boxes the most affordable and convenient
way to get healthy humanely raised meat
uh before they kill it with butcher
bucks you get the highest quality meat
uh for around just six bucks a meal
and they even have free shipping
nationwide except alaska and hawaii
and i'll ask in hawaii i mean jesus
christ look we can you can just [ __ ]
shoot a bear up there
hawaii can climb a coconut tree make
yourself a [ __ ] little drink oh
god do i miss hawaii i gotta do a gig
out there again
right now butcher box is offering new
members ground beef for life
that's two pounds of ground beef in
every box for the life of their
subscription
just go to butcherbox.com that's
butcherbox.com
all right stamps.com as we slowly
adjust to a new normal uh
we still need to be smart about oh my
god i just went
you don't have no idea where my head
just went where my head just went i just
because you know i don't want to fly
commercial because
because um you know i i got
little kids at home and i can't risk and
i want to [ __ ] quarantine for goddamn
14 days
i was just thinking of flying to hawaii
private with my family and the plane
goes down and rather than
mercifully crashing the pilot was able
to land it where we still survive
and there's no raft and we're just
sitting there with their legs dangling
in the water with life preservers on
um jesus christ do i have a fear of the
ocean all right stamps.com
as we slowly adjust to the new normal
the new normal we still need to be smart
about how we do the business
first of all we've already adjusted to
the new normal
okay i don't even remember going to work
anymore i don't know about the rest of
you guys this is just the [ __ ] way it
is
um i don't remember being in comedy
clubs i vaguely remember
that i can't imagine this i can't even
remember the sound of what a packed
theater sounds like all right at this
point i've done
four parking lot shows and i've done
three shows in a corn field and that's
just what it sounds like to me now
so i don't know that it is normal i'm
not adjusting anymore i'm there
um anyways um
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things easier they've been able to keep
their businesses running and avoid the
crowds at the post office
all from their own computers that's
that's phenomenal
i'll tell you all of these people that
have been advertising forever who knew
we always knew they were convenient but
they are perfect for a pandemic
hire from home what have we done here
hire from home
get your meat delivered to your home and
then ship out all the [ __ ] you got
to ship
out from home it's perfect these are
these are perfect pandemic
company models and you'll save money
with discounted rates that you can't
even get at the post office you've heard
me talk about stamps.com they've been
sponsoring the show for over seven years
i think it's eight years at this point
and if you haven't tried it what are you
waiting for stamps.com brings all the
mailing and shipping services you need
right to your computer in the comfort of
your home or office whether you're a
small business sending invoices
an online seller shipping out products
or just working from home
and need to mail stuff stamps.com can
handle it all with ease
uh simply use your computer to print us
postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send
once your mail is ready you just leave
it for your mail carrier
schedule a pickup or drop it in a
mailbox it's just that simple and like i
said with stamps.com you can get great
discounts too five cents off every stamp
and up to 62 percent off usps
united states postal service and united
parcel service shipping
rates stamps.com is a no-brainer saving
you time and money right now
my slash our listeners my listeners uh
get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free
postage at a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bur
that's stamps.com enter bur b-u-r-r
all right okay we're on the back nine
all right we're gonna be doing a little
bit of uh questions and answers little
column responses here
um all right schoolhouse rock
everybody this is the first one i
remember schoolhouse rocky and chip up
the block from your favorite school
house um schoolhouse rock
dear bill did you know amazon prime
has all the episodes of schoolhouse rock
what do you [ __ ] work for amazon i
still feel like i'm doing a read here
um here's just a here
here's just a few as a memory
jogger i actually uh i own all of this
on a cd on cd i just don't have a cd
player anymore
uh just a bill i'm just a bill yes i'm
only up in conjunction junction
what's your function interjection
chess emotion hallelujah uh what about
verb
i do my thing in action
um all right and so on um
you know what's funny is i listened to
all of those as a kid i absolutely loved
them
and then after i stopped watching
cartoons and everything
i started playing drums i tried playing
guitar and all of that and then i gained
an appreciation
for bands and and i got to tell you
something the drumming
on like three's a magic number is just
it is the perfect drum part
um incredible incredible musicians
that are on that thing uh he said i just
sat and watched the ones i remembered
and it was amazed at how well
they put together the songs that had dry
as hell topics like
how a bill is put into a law uh how
catch
how catchy yeah and just [ __ ] you had to
memorize we the people
in order to form a more perfect union
i forget for the common defense um
uh that they put the songs okay uh how
catchy the tunes were and that i
remember them like 30 years later
i could almost sing them word for word
it's also impressive how many
there are how many never aired that i
saw and finally
how many were super anti-british
uh thanks for your time and go [ __ ]
yourself auntie british
i don't know well maybe because that was
put up around
our bicentennial so we were reliving
some of that [ __ ] back then
by the way the british kicked our
[ __ ] ass in the war of 1812
they went to our state our country's
capital
burned the one they had dinner in the
white house and then burned the [ __ ]
down
um which by the way i gotta tell you
something for all the [ __ ] the united
states of america gets for what we did
for native
to native americans and slavery and all
of that [ __ ] which you know admittedly
i mean you can't even it's just it is
what it is it's [ __ ] horrible
the [ __ ] that england did in
india is just i i mean there's just
this is like this is what it's like to
be white well our evil was really evil
but your evil was extra evil
um and what kills me is that they're out
from underneath
the power of uh the oppression of
england yet they kept the caste system
like why would you do that is it because
there's so many
people from india right in man what do
you think about that [ __ ] there
shouldn't be somebody born into poverty
and they have no hope of ever getting
out of it
the same way if you're born into riches
and you can't [ __ ] lose it all
by being a [ __ ] idiot right
um are there just too many people to try
and pull that out it's kind of like over
here like we all knows it's a ponzi
scheme but everybody's bought into it so
you got to keep going with it right
um i don't know it's fascinates me and
also
my one trip to india i fell in love with
the place and the people there
and um i saw some of the most amazing
things there and then i also saw some of
the most heartbreaking things there and
it's just you know
they're fellow human beings and if you
have any sort of a hat you don't want to
see people suffering
so um people from india right in man if
you if you were if you were to
fix your country
two things how would you get rid of the
caste system
um if that is the solution because i
don't want to be the guy who go went
there
one day for [ __ ] i was there for
about 36 hours
and uh number two how would you fix the
population problem
um let me know all right middle east
dear bill remember the middle east uh
yeah i'm still listening to the hair
metal i'm i'm i'm yeah we're still over
there
remember the middle east it's this place
that's far from us that has
little impact on us here in america
except when we need to blow them up for
defensive reasons
uh what do you mean they have little
impact
they basically still provide the
majority of our oil right
that's our energy um we're still dealing
with the fallout of 9 11
and those never-ending wars that we had
over there finally they they did end
afghanistan um
which is not the middle east but i'm
just saying the never-ending wars that
we ended up getting involved in over
there and we
bankrupted the country fighting that
[ __ ] war over there
um so they have a major impact on us
and also they're fellow human beings and
if they're not getting along that's
that's eventually gonna affect over here
uh funny how we don't talk about that
anymore how come
liberals and democrats don't talk about
that anymore
i don't feel like anybody talks about it
i feel like people almost think
we've been at war for so long it just
feels like we're not at war
they just approve military budgets and
no one says
uh peep uh i don't believe republicans
do either and i
i've been saying this forever this is
why i never vote
for democrat or republicans i'm always
going with libertarians
because they seem to be the only ones
going uh corporations
own our politicians and are determining
our foreign policy
i could you know i might be wrong i
might be wrong maybe the democrats are
the only ones not saying anything maybe
the republicans
are the ones um i will give this up to
trump he does talk about never-ending
wars
and afghanistan has ended on his watch
like it or not liberals that has
happened not saying that i like the guy
not saying that he's shown any sort of
[ __ ] leadership during this difficult
time
uh my vote right now the most leadership
i've seen during the pandemic is jerry
seinfeld in what he wrote in
the new york times that's the first
thing that i read about the pandemic
that made me stand up straighter
and make me feel positive um anyways he
goes it's almost like they tell us
what to talk about and think about right
now they show us
violence every day probably to normalize
it so they can make an excuse
to up the domestic military police and
convince us
we need more ruling over
check out matt tabi's book
hate inc uh produced pronounced
taibi okay t-i-e-e-b-e-e you didn't
capitalize any of it so i don't know
where to
stress um it's all about that culture
war being propped up by news outlets for
money all right i love everything you
wrote but i don't like that it was
basically aimed at liberals and that's
the problem
right now is that all criticism of this
country right now
is aimed at either democrats or
republicans
and you got to step outside of all of
that
and you just have to you know it's like
looking at the nba and you have to
understand that the nba has sold its
soul to the super team
and even if your team uh wins a
championship with the pylon team
you still have to step back and say this
isn't good for the league
um despite your your your team loyalty
and i feel the same way about politics
that um
we're just we're on a runaway train we
just are on a runaway train and
um you know that paris agreement where
we were actually going to have to
uh look at alternative sources live a
cleaner lifestyle to pull out of that
okay great saves us money but what is
the f what what is the end game if
you're saving money and you're
destroying the [ __ ] planet which is
what the [ __ ] we're doing
we are doing that so um california
passed the law where all the trucks are
gonna know by 2025 or something
are gonna have to be electric like stuff
like that needs that needed to happen
[ __ ] 30 years ago we are so far
behind
we're like a sixth year senior here
um trying to graduate but i still
because the only thing you can do is
just believe in people i believe that
democrats and republicans at some point
will come together and
it just feels good to say it we got to
come together and and you know something
what it really is is we have to i think
as individuals
we have to be helping out the problems
because
um to put it all on the cops
to put it all on your politicians to put
it all on your
military and then you just get to not
deal with it
you know outsourcing all of those
problems you know if you don't like
what's going on in inner cities you
should get involved in programs
that give people a [ __ ] chance um
and especially if youth if you think
that
um you know
certain races of people choose to live
that way are prone to violence and all
that
go down there and get involved and then
you'll actually meet people and you have
a [ __ ] frame of reference
instead of some ignorant [ __ ] that
somebody
put in your head when you were a kid um
it's one of the great experiences that
i've i've probably the greatest
greatest experience i've had getting
into show business
is traveling this whole country
every state and then going
across canada and then into europe
australia
and went to asia one time and just just
that trip to asia that one time
what that did for my perspective
on people and everything in a very
positive way
um you know it helps
it helps you to sift through all of this
just this [ __ ] evil [ __ ] that they're
spewing out trying to make us hate each
other so
um i don't know and hating people it's
just it's
a lot of energy it's a lot of [ __ ]
energy there's no reason we're
acting like a bunch of goddamn kids here
we literally
live if you see nature
not [ __ ] with we live in eden
and we've [ __ ] it all up
so it would be great can you imagine if
we actually turned this bus around and
we fixed it i mean it won't happen in my
lifetime but just to see the bus turn
around
and you can go back to like being able
to drink out of a river the fact that we
just accept the fact that our rivers and
everything are all polluted by these
[ __ ] goddamn companies
um and i always stay open-minded like
how do you keep seven billion people
alive
maybe that you know that you need
man-made salmon i'm coming around to
that [ __ ] you know
and you see some of these chefs you know
they can take a foam and you drink it
you feel you just had a steak and cheese
sandwich
i don't mind eating like an astronaut in
the future um
i would just like you know clean air and
all that stuff for kids because
you know we're sitting here selfishly
doing all of this [ __ ] we're [ __ ] it
up for future generations all right i'm
done i'm off my [ __ ] stump there
all right so uh oh one last thing yeah
in the future like when you present
arguments like uh a great way for people
to hear what you're saying is not to say
liberals or conservatives you know and
kind of let go of all of that [ __ ]
which is a big ask i think it's almost
like letting go of a [ __ ] religion
uh podcast response uh bill
oh i have a feeling that this is just
gonna be somebody trashing me because
they say it sounded to me from your last
podcast
that you've only read headlines in
social media posts
about 17 year old kid who shot three
people in kenosha
but probably haven't watched the video
yourself no i watched the video
if you've not watched the video i'd like
to hear if your perspective changes
after seeing it yourself it seems clear
to me
that kyle rittenhouse didn't take an
assault rifle as you said
just shoot unarmed innocent [ __ ]
people
it doesn't look to me like he just
decides to take matters into his own
hands and shoots them
the first guy shot was charging at kyle
and throwing some unknown flaming object
in his direction while he was trying to
run away
and hear a gunshot directly behind all
right admittedly
i just i watch grainy footage of this
[ __ ]
but here's here is the thing
here is the thing about all of this [ __ ]
all right a 17 year old kid should not
be walking around
with a [ __ ] assault weapon okay
and then secondly why people are rioting
and all of that stuff like is something
else that white people have [ __ ]
ignored
for hundreds of years there is is also
that
now you should not run at somebody you
should not [ __ ]
uh you know throw a flaming thing at
somebody or anything like that but i do
i do not sign off on [ __ ] people
like i mean i i have to i i would have
to watch all of this [ __ ] thing
um look if somebody comes into your
[ __ ] house
i mean yeah but if you're outside
going down there with a gun to confront
people
then then i don't know i don't know i
don't know
but you are right i haven't watched it i
guess to the level you have
doesn't look to me okay the first guy
shot was charging a cow throwing
some unknown flaming object in his
direction well i mean obviously he can't
do that the second guy
was shot trying to grab his rifle
as he was being kicked in the face by
another protester
the third guy shot was lunging towards
him with the pistol in his hand
before the first shooting he can be seen
on video running away from a group of
people my question though
is why is he there
okay the cops can go down there and
handle this [ __ ]
why is he out there that is my question
and he's retreating
someone behind him fires a gun into the
air imagine running away from a mob of
people hearing a gunshot from behind you
then turning around
okay here's my question for you imagine
putting yourself in the perspective of
those other people
because the problem is is that people
just keep putting themselves into the
perspective of the white person if
they're white
or the black person if they're black the
bottom line is you should not be writing
and the other bottom line is you should
not be going out there acting like you
just deputized yourself
this is a 17 year old kid what the [ __ ]
is he doing out there in the middle of a
[ __ ] riot
there's also that question isn't there
all right at this point
he had to choose between using his rifle
or getting into a fist fight with an
angry mob
um well you're not addressing why he's
out there
after this shooting he does not flee the
scene he grabs his phone and stays with
the victim
however the mob quickly starts moving
his direction begins yelling at him
so he runs away to avoid another
confrontation once again the mob does
not
allow him to flee yeah and he also
inserted himself into this is the thing
that you're ignoring
and the second shooting uh shooting
about a minute later
can be seen jogging down the street with
the group of people chasing him with
something yelling get him
get his ass yeah because he just shot
two [ __ ] people
there's also that okay what you're
acting like is this guy was sitting
inside doing his homework
he went out there to confront he went
out there with a gun
to join it okay now if you don't have
any sympathy for people that went out to
riot
how do you have sympathy for somebody
that went out to confront it who's not a
cop
that that is my question all right now
i'm i'm totally about
i 100 get the self-defense thing you're
saying here but you're not addressing
why he went out there
all right i mean what about that guy
that same thing that guy in florida
where the cops are going don't follow
that kid don't follow that kid
he went out there to have a
confrontation
anyway within two seconds of tripping a
person
tries to kick him in the face while he's
on the ground and a second person
reaches down
grabs the bale of his weapon and is shot
in the chest
he immediately sights his rifle on a man
running towards him with the handgun
the man with the handgun freezes and
puts
puts his hands up for us up
for about a second it appears cal looks
down at his weapon
to clear a malfunction at which point
the man with the handgun lunges towards
him
and is shot in the arm
now okay so now imagine you're trying to
get away from yeah i am i get all of
this stuff
except why he was there
why are you there
why the [ __ ] are you there that's what i
don't get
while someone is screaming for people to
stop you someone sprints up behind you
and throws a a haymaker at the back of
your head
yet what you're ignoring is that he went
down there to confront
he got his confrontation he then got
involved
like what what would you think would
happen if you went down and started
shooting people in a mob
what would you think if you went down
and faced them up
you go down there with your gun
to face a [ __ ] riot and you were
against the rioters like what
put yourself in that other position what
are you gonna do
all right put yourself in the position
of the rioters who've been pulled over
for years and years and years
for no [ __ ] reason at all other than
for being black and they could literally
be driving home
from a night course at college and end
up dead
and the and the people who do it have
never gone to jail
imagine how angry they are
imagine if they're showing up and
there's yet another white person
with the [ __ ] assault weapon walking
around
and no one has a [ __ ] problem with it
because they're white
imagine if you're a black guy and you're
walking down the street after you just
shot a couple of people
who are coming at you or not with your
hands up and the cops just go hey get
out of the way
i mean if you're going to do this put
yourself in the white dude's position
you have to do that on both sides
okay now from what you're saying if it's
if it went down the way
you're saying it went down
then a lot of that all of that
on paper is self-defense but what
i don't understand is why he goes down
there
why does he show up with this [ __ ]
gun what is he doing
he's not a cop he's 17 [ __ ] years old
he should be at home inside
and he should be letting the people
whose job it is to stop it
stop it he doesn't he chooses to go down
there
get involved and face the anger of of
hundreds of years of oppression inserts
himself into that
and is standing there with a [ __ ] gun
okay i would think if i went down with a
gun to a [ __ ] riot i'm eventually
going to run into somebody with a
[ __ ] gun
that's what's going to happen so
i mean i look if that kid was [ __ ]
sitting on his front porch even trying
to defend his house because if they're
going to come and burn down his house
you got a gun you got
you have every [ __ ] right but you
start walking down the you insert
yourself and walk down the [ __ ]
street
you're looking for it isn't he
i don't know i don't know and i this is
another thing too i am not condoning
what people do
in riots i think riots are wrong
i don't think that they they help
what people are trying to achieve
on the other side i definitely believe
that people get hired both
in those new world order [ __ ]
white peaceful protests i definitely
think that the government
hires people to go down there and stir
[ __ ] up i've seen plenty of [ __ ]
videos where they just leave stacks of
bricks
places you know acting like they're
[ __ ] built it's like sitting in the
middle of the [ __ ] road
um there's there's all kinds of
variables here so here's the thing sir
like i i have no problem with gun owners
i have no problem with self-defense
i do have a [ __ ] problem when you're
a 17 year old kid and you decide to just
go down there the same way that [ __ ]
[ __ ] down in florida murdered that
kid
he went down he was looking for a
confrontation he got one and then people
died
um i don't know but having said that i'm
sure
your version of what happened is what's
going to happen because this kid's white
and and he will he will get off i think
that that's what's going to happen and
that's not going to help things
um you know
i don't know that's just how that's just
how i look at it
all right and and you know in defense of
what you're saying
i haven't watched it to the level that
you have watched it
but i also i'm not gonna watch this
video when i do watch it i'm not gonna
watch it like this kid didn't have an
option
to not [ __ ] be there
all right i don't know let me see
something here
before i make a total ass of myself
where like where where did this kid live
where did
does kyle
slowly slowly internet of course
i mean didn't this guy like drive from a
long way away
the reality is i shouldn't be weighing
into this [ __ ] if i know this little
about it that i mean that is the truth
but i
will if this is another classic example
of somebody who did not have to be
involved who was not a [ __ ] cop
and went down there with the [ __ ]
weapon and then gets themselves inserts
themselves into a situation where they
now have to defend themselves
and then kill [ __ ] a couple two three
people
it's like and then you're well you know
self-defense it's just like
what the [ __ ] were you doing you know i
always equated it to like you know i
could [ __ ] you know walk through
central park back in the day
at three o'clock in the morning dressed
like liberace singing i'm in the money
waving my money around
and then when somebody comes up to me
and starts attacking me i think you know
first of all if i get my [ __ ] ass
beat the person who did it is still
wrong but it
this also an onus on me of like what is
your response like why would you put
yourself into that [ __ ] situation
um
all right i mean i don't have time to
read all of this
all right 17 year old shadowed local law
enforcement as a cadet
and filled his social media feed post
declaring that blue lives matter
i mean here's all kinds of [ __ ] here
that you [ __ ]
ignore you're ignoring all of this this
type of [ __ ] you're ignoring [ __ ]
racism
you're ignoring media hysteria and what
you're doing
is you're going to just take this case
and you're going to you're going to
you're going to [ __ ] act like history
and there's nothing up in front of it
and you're just going to press
play when these rioters are coming at
him and be like boom self-defense
you and you're going to ignore all of
that and dude i just can't sign off on
that
all right i just i can't sign off on
that i can sign off on if this kid
stayed home
and some [ __ ] lunatic rioters start
coming up his [ __ ] driveway
then all day long all day long that's
self-defense but you when you [ __ ] go
out of your way
to go down there and get and get into it
with people you know and then oh and
then he always checks the victims okay
and he put his [ __ ] hands up well
what a [ __ ] boy scout
i mean i i i can't sign off on that i
just i i can't
all right i mean i easily in this state
that i live in
could could buy a gun for [ __ ]
self-defense and when the riots were
going on here
i easily could have gone down to where
they were going on
and i could have stood there with a
[ __ ] gun and been yet another white
guy
in front of black people with a [ __ ]
gun
not on their side and i could have gone
down there and i could have got into it
and then when they came at me i guess i
could have shot him
i would have been in trouble because i
want to had a license to carry i guess
but you could have watched that video
and been like you know bill was was just
defending himself it's like
bill didn't need to be there
i didn't need to [ __ ] be there so
um i don't know
i don't know i have i have empathy
for people on both sides if all of a
sudden
because of the ills of society you are
thrusted into something
but when you go out of your [ __ ] way
as a white person to go down there and
confront it
i just that's that's the part that i
have a problem with and i don't have a
problem
with black people protesting
i i hate to see the riots because i
think it works against them
but you know who am i as a [ __ ]
hothead
who can't even go through airport
security without losing his [ __ ]
to sit there and judge somebody that
expresses their frustration of
oppression that way and i'm not saying
that they're that that's only that i'm
not saying that there's not
some piece of shits that just want to go
down there and get some free [ __ ] tvs
and [ __ ] there's always
opportunists i'm not saying that either
but i just i just i can't co-sign on on
the uh
you know going out of your way to stand
in front
of people with a gun and then oh my god
i i had to shoot people
because i i was being attacked um
i don't know i mean that's that's
that's like the [ __ ] chick walking
around with the tits hanging out and
then says what are you looking at
i'm looking at your tits they're hanging
out of your shirt
i don't know all right grandpa help
um that's gonna start a big debate but
you know something i do respect your
opinion
i do respect your opinion and um
you know and you watched way more of it
than i did
i'll just be honest with you the reason
why i don't watch as much of it
is because i i just find it
so depressing to watch white people and
black people
acting that way because someone who came
from an extremely white background
the life that i have lived and now
seeing way more of it
than i did when i was a kid you you just
really see
that there's no reason for any of this
so it becomes overwhelmingly depressing
to see two people that should have been
hanging out having a great time
in an unpolluted world are then shooting
at each other
um and then people just literally
pick teams due to skin color
or political ideologies and all of that
and and
i don't know i just find i find the
whole [ __ ] thing overwhelmingly
depressing
and um yeah that's it i just that's
that's just and i i don't i don't want
to watch this [ __ ] i don't want to watch
fox news
and watch them [ __ ] race baiting i i
don't want to watch
cnn and watch these [ __ ] [ __ ] um
deliberately putting out misinformation
to hurt the standing president
because all they want is their corporate
[ __ ] to get in there
um i it's all just the whole [ __ ]
thing is is depressing overwhelmingly
depressing
but um all right that's it okay grandpa
help
uh hey billy butt licker
uh 33 year old lady here i was wondering
if you could give me some advice on how
to have a better relationship with
my grandpa i love him of course but he's
the quiet stoic type that occasionally
adds a hilarious one-liner
to the conversation that goes back to
watching whatever western movie
is on tv we only see each other on
holidays
and other families uh get-togethers we
might have more in common than i realize
we just never had many one-on-one
conversations
i want to know him better but i don't
know where to start i've known him my
whole life and want to get closer to him
my grandpa died a few years ago
uh my grandma died a few years ago and
we were both devastated now he's very
lonely during the quarantine
and i want to be able to call and chat
but i don't know what to say
thanks for any advice you can give and
of course go [ __ ] yourself
i just bring some food over to him just
call him up one day ask him if he wants
to have lunch
they bring over his favorite sandwich
and you guys sit there
and uh you could start by saying
you know talk about you know
the [ __ ] pandemic and ask him what's
the closest thing he ever went through
in his life that was like this and then
that'll get him talking about the old
days when he talks about the old days
you can ask him more questions that can
lead into uh what was your first car
you can get to know him better then you
can talk about yourself
like i've always found that with um with
older people
is you just take an interest in what
their life was and what they went
through
and you try to relate it to what you're
going through you ask them for advice
and [ __ ]
and then there has to be something that
activity that he's into that maybe
there's an overlap
that you guys could do together um and
maybe it is just
just having lunch with them just start
you know
afterwards say you know i enjoyed this
maybe it would be cool if i come by
every tuesday or whatever day it is
to have lunch with you and just start
doing that and maybe next time you're
coming over a couple times a week
and you but you know if you work on it
you can definitely make it happen
um anyway a number six combo from jack
in the box
and 2 tacos all right uh
hey oh billy bag of bones
i was getting some late night munchies
from my go-to spot taco bell the other
night the other day
when i pulled up the drive-through was
closed when it was supposed to be open
for another two hours i searched for
nearby fast food by the way the number
six combo
from jack-in-the-box with the two tacos
was my late friend wayne preverty's
favorite order
anyways i searched for nearby fast food
joints and jack in the box came up
i've never had jack in the box before as
i was not interested
in a one-stop shop for all your fast
food needs kind of place fast food isn't
all that great for you to begin with
but a joint that serves every type of
food at all hours of the night
uh can't be that good however after
hearing about your friend wayne and your
failed
jack-in-the-box attempt i thought i'd
give it a shot oh that's cool
so i got the number six combo which
actually does have ketchup on it
i didn't know that because i used to get
the ultimate cheeseburger and that had
no ketchup
and two tacos the tacos were [ __ ] i knew
it
unfortunately but for wayne i enjoyed
them that cheeseburger though was
actually pretty [ __ ] good
i will definitely be revisiting to give
some more items a shot
and have another ultimate cheeseburger
in the future
um well back in the day the ultimate
cheeseburger did not have ketchup on it
uh thanks for all the laughs and best
wishes for the future
uh p.s i watched the documentary tread
and it was [ __ ] hilarious uh dude
don't go to the [ __ ]
jack in the box don't don't start eating
those goddamn places that's why i'm
losing friends
um go to the heart doctor see what
you've done to yourself
you know so you can figure it out and
they can hook you up i'm going
i got an appointment coming up um
because that's what it is because i'm at
that age now we're all all of our
we're all paying for our sins so
everybody i got friends now call me up
doc says i can't drink anymore doc says
i can't smoke anymore
it's just uh it's a wrap so
like i've said i've told you guys um
you know save up some fun days
and by the way for everybody who's
really going to react because i know it
was a really hot button [ __ ] issue
there that that
thing that i read okay and um
about that kid because that's the other
two thing too is you're watching a kid
who just threw his [ __ ] life away
you know if it goes down where they
you know he gets convicted um
like i i if you want to be like this guy
who wrote in like i really appreciated
the tone of this like if you want to
come at me like a [ __ ] adult but
if you're going to come hey libtard and
uh
race traitor and all of that stupid [ __ ]
the same way i can't listen to [ __ ]
woke signal signalers however the [ __ ]
you say that
like i just all i want all i want on
this podcast i don't give a [ __ ] if you
don't agree with me i respect your
opinion and i know that i don't i could
be 100
wrong on that kyle rittenhouse thing
okay that's just
my feeling on it and i'm entitled to it
you don't have to name call i'm not
going to do that because i just don't
want to do that [ __ ] anymore i i need to
talk to adults
all right that is all that is a podcast
go [ __ ] yourselves and i will check in
on you
on thursday see ya
you